Stu in the Bible no because are you
Christian don't be dishonest with are
you Christian don't be dishonest I'm
going to show you I'm going to show you
I'm going to show you I'm going to show
you I'm going to show you
don't see this is what they do yeah they
look for new new people in a corner to
have this the debate with these guys are
10 years in the corner all of that I'm
not scared I'm here I'm not scared I'm
here talk I don't want to talk to you
you're not you're not coming
sincerely you're not coming sincerely
that's Jesus talking therefore go and
make disciple of all Nations btis them
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit John 3:16 god of the
world the world John watch watch John
1:10 if anyone comes to you doesn't not
bring this teaching do not receive into
your house or give him any
she's Christi so you should work you
should work what do you mean you about
I'm going to show let me show you the
whole
thing Lial become liberal he become
Lial anyone
anyone if any if anyone comes to you no
look as a Christian yeah so this
teaching for Christian people anyone
comes to you does not bring this
teaching do not receive it into your
house or give him any greeting so if if
she's not Christian you should not greet
her no it's talking about
Muhammad
iach you always need because you know M
outside of my house my house yes mham
mhamad included thank you very
much the Bible is Jesus came for the
Jews and the Gentiles if we are
Gentiles no she's not includ have to
love
each I love you but I hate that ideology
you can love
can Nation or
no am I
contradiction
contradiction are you talking step by
step step step so you saying we're going
to come down there okay pushing the
camera you're pushing the camera be
careful so he said is you said Jesus
love all the nations yeah including
myself yeah course is Muhammad Nation
part of the nation Muhammad is not a
nation is he part of the nation of
nation no answer be honest is Muhammad
part of the nation I know I'll go you
there I know
[Music]
[Applause]
theree back told me